[موسيقى]
الملك تشارز الثالث هو اعلى سلطه في
المملكه المتحده وايرلندا الشماليه يتمتع
بصلاحيات الملكيه ينص عليها الدستور
البريطاني غير المكتوب ولكن السلطات الملك
في الحاضر رمزيه وبروتوكوليه
للملك عدد من الوظائف ذات طابع سياسي من
تعيين رئيس وزراءها حصل حزبه على اكبر عدد
من مقاعد البرلمان لتشكيل حكومه جديده الى
افتتاح البرلمان الرسمي في احتفال تقليدي
يلقي فيه خطابا من كرسي العرش في مجلس
اللوردات خطاب يتضمن برنامج الحكومه في
الدوره البرلمانيه الجديده يلتقي كذلك
وزير الخزانه سنويا قبل تقديم الموازنه
للعموم كما يقوم الملك ايضا بحل البرلمان
قبل اجراءات انتخابات عامه
من مهام الملكه ايضا المصادقه على مشاريع
القوانين التي يقر البرلمان قبل ان تصبح
قانونا ونظريا يمكن للملك رفض الموافقه
على القوانين لكن المره الاخيره التي
استخدم فيها ملك بريطانيا هذا الحق كانت
قبل ثلاثه قرون وكان ذلك في عهد الملكه ان
اسبوعيا يلتقي الملك برئيس الحكومه
للاطلاع على برامجها كما يتراس اجتماعات
شهريه لمجلس الملك الخاص ويقوم بمجموعه من
التعيينات بناء على توصيات حكومته
يستضيف الملك رؤساءه وممثل الدول الزائرين
ويقبل اعتمادات السفراء الاجانب وتشارز
الثالث هو ايضا اعلى سلطه في اربع عشره
دوله اخرى في دول الكومنواز
الملك تشارز الثالث يسود ولا يحكم هو رمز
الهويه الوطنيه والوحده والشعور
بالاستقرار والاستمراريه الكثير من
صلاحيته قل استخدامها مع مرور الزمن ولو
ان وجودها يعتبر امرا مهما في النظام
الملكي الدستوري السائد في بريطانيا مصطفى
زاروه العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات